hot breath i like you use the word brand
because that's something you
have just mastered in this game and you
being
so diverse in your business all the way
from stand up to
voice over work and video games to like
broad ways yeah like
this this branding aspect of a comedian
what kind of branding tips do you have
for a comedian i mean you know and again
it's the the key thing is
that you know you have to be able to
listen to your audience
and and and your fan base and really see
what they really like about
you and then try to hone into those
things and
and then make them sharper and crisper
uh it takes a you know it takes a
village to
build something up in you know in a way
that you know you know again like you'll
take this
podcast and you'll grow this into a tv
show or series right
but there's you know the idea comes in
having people that
really you know start to see exactly
what your vision is
and then you insisting upon that like
insisting on assisting upon
what it is that you dream about and try
how you make that come true and so
you know for me all these opportunities
opportunities to be on um
on the broadway stage opportunities to
go from just not just stand up into
television and from television to movies
all of them were strategic they were
strategic kind of pushes and things that
i look for and i look for the right
opportunities for me to go
and be as authentically me in the spaces
and safe without necessarily trying to
get the money first
you know